During Marvel Studios' panel at San Diego
Comic-Con 2019, Avengers: Infinity War and
Endgame screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely revealed that Mark Ruffalo's
Bruce Banner was initially meant to merge
with his mean, green alter ego the Hulk in
Infinity War rather than in Avengers: Endgame.
According to Polygon, Markus and McFeely explained
that one of the most difficult things to get
right was crafting the big character moment
where Banner finally settles his differences
with the Jade Giant, brings together his brain
with the Hulk's brawn, arising a smart version
of the Hulk.
The duo wanted the character's arc to make
sense, with viewers easily understanding the
motivations behind and methods of Banner's
metamorphosis, but it turned out to be more
complicated than they initially thought.
As Markus explained, the Infinity War team
wrote and filmed the whole transformation,
saying:
"He achieved union with the Hulk while inside
the Hulkbuster.
He kicked Cull Obsidian's ass."
Banner and Hulk becoming one while wearing
the Hulkbuster armor was such a hit with the
Infinity War crew, they swiftly moved along
to shoot Avengers: Endgame, thinking everything
was ship-shape and would be satisfying for
fans.
But Markus and McFeely found flaws in their
plan to introduce Professor Hulk in Infinity
War.
"If it works, it's gonna work, and you have
a lot of chances to find that out.
And if it doesn't work, we'll circle back
around."
In their eyes, the magic of the Hulk-Banner
union subsequent butt-kicking of Black Order
underling Cull Obsidian faded fast, and they
realized they absolutely couldn't have that
in the film.
Markus said:
"It didn't work.
It was the wrong tone for the movie.
A big sequence where you see the union take
away from the attention of the story."
There was a big problem, though: directors
Joe and Anthony Russo had already filmed Avengers:
Endgame, where Banner and Hulk had merged.
So it was reshoots to the rescue.
Markus and McFeely re-worked the Endgame script,
Banner actor Ruffalo came back to set to re-film
some sequences, and the theatrical cut of
Infinity War was permanently changed.
As fans will recall, Banner does indeed join
his fellow heroes to take down Thanos and
his army of aliens across the plains of Wakanda
in Infinity War.
And yes, he does wear Tony Stark's Hulkbuster
armor, because Banner had trouble bringing
Hulk to the surface after his initial, failed
scrap with Thanos at the beginning of the
movie.
Following that tussle, which resulted in Loki's
death, Banner couldn't "Hulk out" no matter
how hard he tried.
"How we doing? Really really good.  "
"Do you plan on helping out?"
"I'm trying!
He won't come out!"
Banner's arc in Avengers: Infinity War contradicted
plot points teased in the film's trailers.
One featured Hulk in his full green glory
fighting side by side with Earth's Mightiest
Heroes.
After fans saw Infinity War on the silver
screen and knew Hulk didn't show up during
that final fight, it was believed that the
clips shown in the trailers were examples
of Marvel intentionally misdirecting fans
to keep spoilers at bay.
With Markus and McFeely's recent reveal, it
stands to reason that the clips of Hulk in
the Infinity War trailers may have come from
before the big change was made.
Smart Hulk appears in Avengers: Endgame after
the five-year time jump from 2018 to 2023.
The film offered a simple explanation as to
how the Banner-Hulk union happened: Banner
spent 18 months in the gamma lab before finding
a way to fuse his smarts with Hulk's strength.
"I put the brains and the brawn together.
And now look at me!"
Professor Hulk shares the information with
his Avengers pals over breakfast, where he
wolfs down pancakes and takes photos with
young fans.
Markus said of the moment in Endgame,
"A scene where Hulk eats a stack of pancakes
[...] I've never seen that in a movie."
While it would have been cool to see Banner
and the Hulk collide in Infinity War, Markus
and McFeely's ultimate decision to save Professor
Hulk for Avengers: Endgame makes more sense.
It may have undercut a moment of personal
triumph for Banner to follow it with the Snap.
Both Endgame and Infinity War got rave reviews
for their perfect balances of action, comedy
and emotion.
Had the screenwriters stuck to their original
plan, the reception may have been different.
"Time travel!"
"Oh my God."
"What?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.